okay we have a super busy week this week
and I just want to let everybody know
what we have that we are doing in case
you want to participate because we don't
normally do this much stuff so we have a
full week this week of shows and bonus
shows so we've got the our show and the
15-minute bonus show Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday we do have
impeachment inquiry hearings live with
my commentary and the way that we've
been doing it is trying to schedule the
filming of the show to accommodate the
impeachment inquiry hearings and it
should not affect the time that the
program the daily program is released so
today we streamed on youtube youtube.com
slash the david pakman show hours of
impeachment hearings lieutenant-colonel
vin minh and many other witnesses today
tomorrow wednesday we again have more
impeachment inquiry hearings which we
will be streaming live it could be
another six hours
join us at youtube.com slash the David
Pakman show
tomorrow we will have Gordon sunland at
9:00 a.m. which will be a really big
deal and then the afternoon session 2:30
p.m. Eastern Time Wednesday we'll hear
from Laura Cooper the Deputy Assistant
Secretary of Defense and David Hale the
Undersecretary of State they will
testify that's on YouTube then we get to
Wednesday night Wednesday night we have
a Democratic presidential debate
it'll be moderated by a Rachel Maddow
Andrea Mitchell Kristen Welker and
Ashley Parker we will have that live on
twitch at twitch TV slash David Pakman
probably will kick it off like a
half-hour early and then potentially
we'll take some phone calls after and
then Thursday we have more impeachment
inquiry hearings 9:00 a.m. we are going
to carry the hearing on the YouTube
channel with Fiona Hill Fiona Hill is
the former Senior Director for Europe
and Russia at the National Security
Council and also David Holmes whose
political counselor at the US Embassy in
Kiev or keeve as it is now predominantly
pronounced at least during the
impeachment hearings that'll be at
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
so it is a major week it's like more
than
double overtime but it's okay because
this is important stuff I think it's
important to carry it and we're going to
be doing it in addition to all of the
news of the day on the regular broadcast
next week we will have a short week it's
going to be because of the Thanksgiving
holiday Monday Tuesday Wednesday that's
it and then Thursday Friday next week we
will be off so that is basically the
game plan and we will continue covering
important events I think from basically
I was talking to some other hosts it's
actually really interesting what's going
on in progressive left media right now
the hosts I talked to which don't really
include people from from certain wings
of the left but the hosts I talked to
that are you know some of the prominent
left people we all are basically
prepared for this is going to be an
absolutely insane year now 300 and what
1217 350 348 or so days up until the
election we anticipate that it's going
to be debates hearings we've got the
State of the Union which we will of
course carry live early in the new year
so it is going to be broadcast show
consistently and of course a lot of
these live events and somewhere in there
we have to sneak in one of our famous
six-month vacations which everybody
seems to be very very angry about no I'm
kidding but we will of course have time
off in there so thanks to everybody
who's been participating in the live
streams I wish all media outlets were
covering all of this stuff but even when
they do sometimes the commentary is is
not the best so we're glad to do it it's
all available free there's no pitch here
there's no ask for money on the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the david
pakman show subscribed there for the
impeachment hearings the twitch channel
twitch.tv slash david pakman for the
debate tomorrow night and many other
things upcoming